c'est l'aveu de ce qu'une majorité de
libanais dénonce depuis près d'une
semaine
catastrophe qui a frappé les libanais au
coeur est arrivé à cause de la
corruption endémique en politique dans
l'administration et dans l'état la
corruption est plus forte que l'état a
dit le premier ministre hassan diab en
annonçant la démission de son
gouvernement pour que je vérifie les
mots forts c'est le dol saluée comme une
victoire par certains ça ne suffit pas
pour calmer la colère des protestataires
dans l'avenue qui mène au parlement ils
n'ont pas attendu la fin du discours du
premier ministre démissionnaire pour se
faire entendre
une fois de plus le centre ville de
beyrouth a été la froide affrontements
explosif entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre qui sont intervenues de façon
plus musclée pour contenir la foule où
la démission du gouvernement ne va pas
assez loin
un geste trop facile 3 gisèle doren on
voit que du noir devant c'est tout le
système qui doit tomber pas que les
ministres et les députés
il devrait être tenu responsable de ce
qui s'est passé et ce n'est pas à nous
les jeunes de subir les conséquences de
leurs actions n'est pas à nous de tout
balayer alors qu'il ne nous regardent
même pas titel n'est peut-être pas à eux
de le faire mais ce sont bien les jeunes
libanais que l'on croisait encore
aujourd'hui occupés à débarrasser les
rues et les maisons des débris qui sont
autant de blessures que celles subies
par les victimes de la double explosion
carla n'a que 15 ans et réalise qu'elle
et sa famille ne peuvent compter que sur
la solidarité de ses concitoyens
les gens nous ont aidés mais le
gouvernement nous a rien nous aurait à
donner
ni à manger ni rien alors c'est une
catastrophe si bien que le restaurateur
dany shakur se prépare à ouvrir les
portes de ses restaurants et pour
protester il a décidé de ne plus verser
la taxe de vente dans les coffres de
l'état
niveau donner l'argent à ceux qui en
font bon usage dit il on va faire nos
déclarations comme prévu mais au lieu de
verser la tva au ministère des finances
la tva sera versé à une liste de sept
associations non gouvernementales qui
vont je pense faire un meilleur usage de
cet argent que l'état il espère que
l'idée fera boule de neige pour que la
pression sur les dirigeants viennent
d'ailleurs que petit slogan et des
débris lancés dans les rues par les
protestataires
c'est loin d'être la fin de la crise
politique pour le liban le pays est
plongé dans l'inconnu
les pressions de la communauté
internationale pour la formation rapide
de nouveau gouvernement et des réformes
en profondeur sont inédites mais le
président michel aoun nuit ne semble pas
pressée de nommer un nouveau chef de
gouvernement
pas plus que des élections anticipées ne
se pointe à l'horizon
la patience des libanais n'a pas fini
d'être mise à rude épreuve ici marie-eve
bédard radio-canada beyrouth